Ось так, силою поліція відтягує захисників довкілля від тракторів, що мають вивозити вирублені дерева
з лісу. І день і ніч тут триває боротьба екологів з владою за один з найбільших та найстаріших лісових масивів рівнинної Європи - Біловезьку пущу.
Попри те, що цей ліс є об'єктом світової спадщини ЮНЕСКО, польська влада дозволила втричі збільшити тут вирубку дерев і стверджує,
що в такий спосіб навпаки - рятує ліс. Річ у тім, що Біловезька пуща потерпає від нашестя жуків-шкідників, які поїдають кору і тим самим нищать
дерева. Мовляв, вирубкою хворих дерев влада рятує здорові. До кінця року Варшава планує вирубити щонайменше один мільйон дерев.
Екологи з цим категорично не згодні. На їхню думку, вирубка є грубим втручанням у природню екосистему
і по суті знищує її. Окрім того, під виглядом боротьби з жуками-шкідниками,
злочинно вирубують здорові дерева, стверджують екологи. На сторону захисників природи став і Брюссель.
Суд Європейського Союзу, куди з позовом проти Польщі звернулася Єврокомісія, ще на минулому тижні, розпорядився призупинити
вирубку реліктового лісу доти, поки суд розглядатиме позов. Однак у Варшаві вже заявили: рішення суду дотримуватися не будуть.
ЄС пригрозив Польщі штрафом у 4 мільйони євро і ще по триста тисяч євро штрафу за кожен день
порушення вимоги суду. Біловезька пуща розташована на території Польщі і Білорусі.
Її загальна площа - понад три тисячі квадратних кілометрів.